what makes you spot someone that's a
heart attack damn whoo dagger
Sophie's Alexi is in a house on
certified country wait Jenna party
ass-backwards right there it works
one more time hey it's John bardy
watching certified country with Sophie
shall I see boom
[Music]
happy Friday party people welcome back
to another edition of certified country
now if you've been watching the show
regularly first of all thank you so much
I love you you're amazing flaw secondly
you may picked up on my low-key
obsession with John party and heartache
on the dance floor
[Music]
and I'm not the only one who's here for
it and then uh probably hardly gonna
dance floor John Park I used that one
recently that's one of my favorites
certified country right here she knows
how she's thought that's my jam
heartache on the dance floor John party
that has come up a lot just a massive
John party family well guess what TR
since I know you're watching the moment
has finally arrived I've got John party
in the flesh on this week's episode of
certified country and he is spilling
some tea on the story behind that song
his heartfelt new single and working
with Miranda Lambert we may have gotten
him in trouble on that one
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
I need you to indulge me though because
hardik on the dance floor is like my jam
did you kind of expect it to get the
response that it has gotten I don't want
to sit here yeah I knew who's gonna be
champ
could be everybody no you know as a
songwriter I just want to be fun you
know it's always awesome to see like
people really enjoying it because it's
it's dancey it's country and it's got a
cool kind of story to it and people
really picked up on it and that's that's
what kind of humbles me and it makes me
feel really what makes a heartache on
the dance floor like what makes you spot
someone that's a hardy the story behind
that song it's kind of based on like you
know you know this is a great story it
happens a lot you know cameras go and
then you don't get information and you
just kind of always like hoping he might
run into her again and that was kind of
his heartache and he was always kind of
looking for and hoping he'd run into her
again and that's kind of like sad in a
way you know it was kind of a sad lonely
happy song yeah all right so let's talk
about the single No
[Music]
see you face I swear
we're going from Harding on the dance
floor to actual heartache now Shane
Annette why was this the right choice to
be the next thing doc no we got three
number ones and things are going great
in like why not throw a curveball in
there you know I might say a little bit
fun dancing this one's kind of like kind
of hits the heart so I think his artist
it's cool to be like boom boom boom boom
boom but it's nice to throw in through
the heartfelt song here and see how it
does it radio I heard it a year before
we even went to the studio so I held on
to that thing the guy they wanted to
record and put it on hold which was
George Strait and I was like oh this is
our first time like really sitting down
so I like to do this speed-dating round
okay these are real questions that I
pulled on speed dating website what
color best describes your personality
speed the process of that's a deep
question
I mean Green Green okay why cuz it's my
favorite color
represents leaves and grass and so if
you could be someone else for a day who
would you be dead or alive I totally do
this per day all right
that would be so cool like yeah driving
around Cadillacs back in time if you won
the lottery how would you suddenly do
charity and make sure I'm financially
set and take some time off you gotta
take take care of my friends what is the
most adventurous thing that you've ever
done little bit to us is it get a little
dicey under bus I always have fear like
the one turn that goes off the cliff
just like what would a big bus be like
floating in
[Music]
20:17 was a huge year for you I think
2018 is gonna be even bigger kicking
things off with the Miranda Lambert or
yeah hello love Miranda she's awesome
she's a cool person yeah so I miss I got
cool browser I've sinned Airport bar
somebody attacked my children turn
around with Miranda just like hey I saw
you at the bar like use it over your bar
so I just want to say hey you guys talk
about secret information Wow but it's an
exciting prospect don't jump out the
birthday cake not time yet get back in
that cake we got in trouble we should be
friends
are you thinking about the next album
I'm always thinking about the next you
gotta be yeah we could eight songs and
still trying to get vocals in being on
the road battling allergies talking a
lot okay doesn't make it hard to be a
hundred percent to go in and nail vocals
so it does take a while slowly but
surely we should be done but those eight
by this year and then we're gonna go
next year and cut another eight and then
hopefully by the beginning of 2019 now
we'll be out no rest no rest but we're
gonna put an EP out next year so we will
have new music but it will be the
official third record
thank you for watching before you go
click the link in the description and
ring the bell so you never miss an
episode of certified country I'm gonna
be taking some time off to enjoy
Thanksgiving with my family next week
but come back and see us again on Friday
December 1st for a brand spankin new
episode whit wait for it Keith Urban we
are gonna be talking all about his new
music and I'm gonna show you what it's
really like behind the scenes of some of
these interviews it is pretty hilarious
so I will see you then